so we work at gtri gtri the Georgia Tech
Research Institute it's the academic arm
of Georgia Tech so I feel like we're
kind of an ACC land up here so I can
cherish our acct I the GTR is a
reasonably large organization we're only
about fourteen hundred engineers about
2000 staff with a with a focus where we
tend to be much more on the applied side
of things and with a big focus on DoD
work that's probably our it is our
primary customer and a lot of our work
is in the space of electronic warfare
which I'll talk about a little bit so I
will talk about kind of what our problem
is that we're trying to solve and then
we can kind of dive into a little bit
about what what that means from a data
standpoint so as I said we well we are
at gtri do a lot of work in electronic
warfare which kind of our background so
for those that are not familiar that's
basically all the different technologies
that come together to protect an
airplane you know detecting radar is
detecting missiles jiaming radars you
know shooting out you know flares to try
to confuse missiles things like that and
our work specifically focuses on
integrating things together so a lot of
times on a platform you end up with
these very specific solutions that have
a niche use case but there's nothing
that brings it all together and as air
crews have gotten smaller there's a need
to try to bring that together so we
we've been writing various products that
have been on a lot of different older
airplanes that try to integrate that
together in the main thing that's been a
focus of ours of the last few years has
been work in the correlation infusion
world so if you look at that picture to
the right what you see is a whole lot of
tracks on a display those little white
symbols represent aircraft in the air
space now one thing you may notice is is
that there are for the most part one
symbol for an area of the airspace in
other words you don't have a lot of
overlapping symbols well that's not an
easy problem to solve they are doing a
lot of fusion under the hood to make
that happen because they have lots of
sensors
that are seeing the same thing and then
they've got it's okay well we believe
this is the same thing and and obviously
you have that in three-dimensional space
and there's a lot of factors that feed
into that so we write the algorithms
that would make a display like that
although our display is not nearly as
cool I that make a display like that but
that use that work on older airplanes
that typically have a much less awesome
sensors and deal with a lot of other
issues like latency and things that make
the data quite nasty um so so this is
that this is what we do and we so you
know on my electrical engineer by trade
so is Jimmy Jimmy also moonlights as a
native developer for those that come out
of the you know that come out of the
pure software world you may have heard
of Ada and you can actually meet someone
that still writes data which is which is
cool and I've got the shout out to Ada
Lovelace for those that know who she is
so the so we our day job is to write
software goes on airplanes but as part
of that we get a bunch of data back that
we got to make sensitive and so we've
you know kind of found ourselves in a
situation with a whole lot of data and
trying to figure out smart ways to
handle it so so the most basic level the
aircraft lands bunch of binary data
comes out it goes into a big dock you
later and then you know thumbs up
everything work I mean realistically
it's not exactly thumbs up everything
worked it's a little more questionable
that but as we all know here there's
somebody in the loop and so our goal is
not to write the gonk you later that
says that it worked our job is to put
the tools in the hands of that guy so
that he can decide what worked and what
didn't work and we tend to be on the
side of the house not on there's a test
organization that vets stuff and that's
separate from us we typically are on the
did our stuff do what we wanted to do
and if it didn't do what we wanted it to
do why did I not do what we want it to
do which sometimes can be a really
complicated question and we need tools
to help us figure that out so a little
context about data and these numbers you
know are very rough but so I use the
term shorty so a sortie means a moment
or in an inch an event where you have an
aircraft take off and land that's a
sortie so for every time that you have
an aircraft is in the sky we call that
sorting a mission is when you have a
handful of aircraft to go fly together
and usually that's about two hours long
so they typically fly to 24 ship
depending on the situation we instrument
and record all the data on the aircraft
that are part of the test you know that
could be as little as one that could be
as many as let's say eight sometimes
it's bigger but usually that's the
maximum there's a ton of error of
aircraft that are in the air space as
well other than the aircraft that are
instrumented which makes figuring out
the right answer a little bit more
complicated but from a data perspective
we get these these these missions and
it's a nominally about 20 gigabytes of
data per sortie a lot of thats video we
do not currently do anything with that
video it's all the cockpit displays and
all these other things we don't do
anything with the video but it's
intertwined in with the binary data so
we can't process the binary data without
working our way through the through the
video so so that that big number matters
um we not only have about a terabyte of
a binary data on the order of seven six
and a half seven terabytes of total data
and a lot of intermediate data and I'll
talk a lot about that I mean that's kind
of a mess we we found ourselves in as we
start producing lots of stuff and then
you end up with these pieces along the
way and trying to figure out how to how
to best handle that and I'll talk about
that a little bit as we as we move
through so a little bit about the
evolution so you know you rewind back
you know 10 12 years ago and we at that
time we were never worried about what
happened across aircraft it was always a
single aircraft so I'd have a single i'd
have an aircraft data file and I would
you know do whatever it took to get the
data into something that I could shove
into Excel and then you know that's back
then you know Excel was probably limited
to you know 64,000 rows so we had way
more data that she had to do some
decimate decimation and things to get
the data manageable and you can excel
and it would be unbelievably painful you
know if you accidentally clicked on a
cell it would recalculate for 45 minutes
and you would cry for a little so so we
sort of steel say everyone when today
would say that that Excel is it isn't is
an asinine tool for this and I think we
quickly agreed with that so we ended up
a migrating into the hole it did a
decent mount of work in Pearl the reason
simply being that a lot of
a lot of the developers had been using
Perl for a long time kind of as part of
their build process and as part of their
kind of working through getting all
their software to do what they wanted to
do and so you know honestly their pearl
books laying around and people started
writing pearls so it was kind of a pearl
good new stack and and I'll talk a
little about what what we did with canoe
and then and then we had that and still
people put right in a lot of matlab you
never write comes out of college right
matlab and they think that's awesome so
but it doesn't handle large data at all
very well in and so plus it costs lot of
money that's for silly the so we said
okay we need to get off everybody awful
needs these separate tangents and kind
of focus so we you know safe probably
five years ago we made a decision to all
kind of get back get within the the PI
data stack and and that has evolved so
we're now everybody works inside that
stack but there's a lot of pieces that
I'll kind of get into with that and then
that kind of last evolutionary piece
which is the hard part of trying to
compare data across aircraft income with
that I imagine most everybody in here is
familiar with this book I just wanted to
mention it from the standpoint that you
know it was kind of hilarious we we've
been doing writing code and trying to
make sense out of our data and then we
stumble across this book and it was like
reading a book that was exactly written
for our problem and it was amazing you
know Jimin are laughing about the fact
that we had we'd written quite a bit of
code that was probably not overly good
and was completely unnecessary once we
realized what pandas was and like wow
Interpol I saw that for you that's
phenomenal um so it was great and I
would say you know Wes weekend he's
still an influence on you know we you
know you tend to pay attention to what
he's doing because a lot of the types of
problems he's trying to solve are very
much in line with the types of problems
that we're trying to solve so kind of at
a basic level here's our process and we
have we don't support just one aircraft
and we don't support one project so this
process is a little different depending
on the aircraft from the project but in
general you know we get a bunch of
flight test data that we got to go to
code and it's a bunch of binary
timestamp data and you need some magical
decoder ring because it's hundreds and
hundreds of messages that some vendor
writes a document that tells you how to
decode that data that data chat thing
changes periodically in
that comes with its own headaches
there's also what I call this kind of
mapper because you know this sensor says
that that aircraft is number 29 means an
f4 or whatever and and so you got to
have all that usually that stuff's not
machine readable and so there's some
some work that has to be done there and
then you go kind of through this
iterative you know munging wrangling
interpretation process the storage thing
is something that we have struggled with
and I'll talk a little bit about that
and kind of what our current a solution
is and then obviously the whole point of
it all the analysis and I'll talk about
that a little bit as well so I'll kind
of hit those three main points so you
know again we are data almost always
comes to us in these things called Iorek
chapter 10 which doesn't need to mean
anything to you except to say that it's
a single large you know 20 gigabyte file
with everything that was recorded on
that airplane all intertwined it's
pretty nasty how I mean obviously
they're writing lots of stuff real time
so it's all intertwined and it's an it's
a bit of a process to get it untangled
there's a an open-source c++ library
that was written that we we leverage to
do that we've basically written a python
wrapper around it that allows us to get
the data so that that part is is
relatively easy at least get it at at I
rigged a container but then we got to go
through this decoder reprocess and you
know as I mentioned you know that that
could be pretty intensive because
there's a lot of messages a lot of
different ways things get formatted one
of the things that we did that was I
think critical was machine making a
machine readable version of that decoder
ring one of things it ended up we
basically kind of extended an XML file
to define how to read that binary string
and then so now you have hundreds to
thousands of messages and they each have
an xml file telling you how to decode
them there's still some weaknesses there
because there's places where a field way
up here tells you how to interpret a
field down here and things like that
that we haven't made that work as well
as it needs to we also found that that
can be relatively slow we want to look
at moving that to something else and
also versioning it where we can know
exactly when you decode something what
version of that you know decoder ring
database you worked with but one of the
problems is is there's the decoder ring
is never machine readable it's typically
a word file some of these things
hilariously were written by some vendor
you know 20 years ago and the only thing
anyone has is some scanned copy that you
can barely read and it's through trial
and error that you actually figure out
you know oh that was two's complement or
whatever so another problem that we have
to to work with this is timestamp
alignment so you know still today many
many of these aircraft struggle mightily
with getting a consistent time stance
throughout the airplane so you think
that it would simply take GPS time ever
you know all these aircrafts do you have
gps I can take ups time and I can
disseminate the problem is is that you
have a lot of different interfaces a lot
of old interfaces but with latency you
had a lot of systems that reboot you
know when they reboot they lose time and
they don't necessarily get resynchronize
so there's just a lot of issues so you
end up having a bunch of different
timestamp stealth aircraft it's a
process you know to go figure out how to
address that across across airplanes
it's it's it's even harder again ideally
everybody is on GPS time and then it's
it's a you know it's easy but it's never
that easy because these aircraft have
drift Anand not insignificant amount of
drift and in just other things you know
that they're just you know people forget
to set things or whatever now I will say
you know timezone got mentioned earlier
you know women it's nice about this
world is that everybody works in UTC
nobody plays in time zones at all we do
get the issue that that we do a lot of
testing out west and the the roll over
is like an 8pm which it's not uncommon
that we have tests the app and over roll
over and that's bitness more times than
we'd like to say so another thing is
coordinate frame alignment so for those
not familiar you know there's a lot of
different ways we can represent a point
spaced and we typically think in lat
long lat long we typically don't think
in el suits as most of us are standing
here on the dirt on the ground but in
general that's the way people talk about
lla lat long altitude that's one way to
do it another way that's much more it's
much better from a computation
standpoint is to try to get things in ec
f x y z which is where the center of the
earth is 0 0 0 and i can tell a
representing in the world and obviously
above the ground in Xyz which is nice
and so but but not everybody reports
that way people reporting different ways
there's also a little new on
is like for those that aren't we all
typically work in what's called a wgs84
model of the world and that pretends
that we have this ellipse and it's an
ellipse that has you know certain things
like flattening and things that we can
find it but still ellipse well the world
is an ellipse it's kind of a lumpy blob
that is not exactly the lips and there's
places where the lumpy this is a little
bigger in places where it's a little
littler and that's what we call the
ellipsoid you know height difference and
it's basically databases that have that
information and you know it can go up
and down you know 20 30 feet so there's
things like that that make it where you
know are we really connect to fix then
you've got that's how we represent
things relative the earth then we've got
the fact that we gotta represent things
relative to aircraft there's a lot of
every ways to do that and then sometimes
a sensor will do a relevant to them you
know the face of the sensor not really
airplane crashed you got to do with that
so that takes there's a decent amount of
work to kind of get all your coordinates
line um as I mentioned you know kind
another shout out the pins and I wish I
knew who did this artwork I found it
online one time and thought it was kind
of awesome the pan is there's a whole
lot of heavy lifting for us when it
comes to munching and wrangling all the
data and again I mean we you know
nowadays that's kind of everything is
within the data frame construct so I'll
get into this a little bit but but as
you know for some of our big projects we
we end up with this where were we we end
up with this big pipeline where we would
run it and it would go you know
translate a whole bunch of data and do a
bunch of comparisons and and do a bunch
of you know correlation analysis we're
figuring out what what the right
decision was as far as what aircraft
will be associated and it would take a
very long time does take a very long
time so we've looked at ways to improve
it and this is something we started
adopting although I would say there's
some experimentation to be done still
numerical expressions is a a library
that has a couple of benefits but
basically the way it works is you put in
as a string basically your your math and
you can put all the math kind of in one
string and then numerical expressions
goes and figures out the smartest way to
execute that kind of with vectorize data
so you know with num peas or data frames
or whatever and in its it's a you know
defaults to being a a parallel I
solution it also takes advantage of
Intel's MKL library so there's a lot of
goodness in that
I we went and ran some data just to you
know and I think we we kind of
notionally done this but but actually to
get it all in place was a little
interesting in the preparations for this
so so what the the first line is telling
you is simply I took a million points
where I went and created a list of a
million items where each one was a tuple
with with lat long and altitude and then
it for the numpy it was a you know three
what you know 1d arrays of a million a
million blatta two million longitude
million on suit and then pandas it was
basically just a single day of frame
with those values and then uh and then
numba so for those unfamiliar with numb
but number is this idea that all it the
only code is at GI t that you put at the
top of your function and what it does is
it pre compiles that function so that
when you rerun that function it's a
precompiled version meaning you're not
having to go do the interpreter again so
it can theoretically be quite speedy
also we did a run with scythe on the the
scythe on is where you're actually
implementing c code inside of python and
it you know it can be a little hairy
because you basically have to you know
kind of build it through a sea process
etc but so what you see here is that uh
you know you week we got up to forty
percent faster now one of the things
that i think is a little bit misleading
about the Zeta is best i can tell
numerical expressions i know numerical
expressions is using all four cores
appropriately I do not think that's
happening with anybody else there's
somewhat of a an unfair 4k or 4x
multiplier on the numerical expressions
data if that if you know so but if you
look at some of these data I mean you
know scythe on for example which I'm
pretty confident was not doing parallel
function 61 milliseconds for a million
points was quite good you know compared
to the 2 2 full seconds with with native
Python but numerical expressions has
been kind of what we've been leaning
with and it's it's quite quite easy to
integrate and it obviously works for you
with numpy and pandas so all this is is
on github which is my SL starts github
so so story so this is a little bit of a
I'd say we're we're weakest and we were
most looking to to change kind of how we
do business
so originally a you know we had there's
all these tools that it existed for a
long time in the flight test data
community in general the flight test
data community which is quite large I
has no concept of you know you know the
scientific Python stack earning like
that like there I think the Venn diagram
overlap is exceptionally small they have
their own tools you know quite a lot of
them and and they and so there was a lot
of tools that we leverage that would
take like eirick data and turn it into
csv s so we end up with lots of CSVs i
was kind of a starting point and it was
like okay real CSVs do some computation
but then the problem is is it along this
process we create a lot of data right
you should say okay I need to know where
this aircraft is that's a message maybe
that's a CSV and then I need to know
where the sensor is looking you know for
the purpose that flight that's that's
that's a data file and then I've got to
compare that sensor to what I believe to
be the truth value so I have a position
on the aircraft that I believed he was
tracking so now I need that and then
that's the comparison information and
then maybe I aggregate something and
that's something else and what we end up
with this is a ton of CSVs now CSVs has
an inherent goodness in the fact that in
you know anybody can open a CSV and it's
valuable out of the gate right you can
open Excel you can plot with it you do
things and one of the things that we try
to do is to have the data be accessible
to the non Python ESA's and and
especially you know we're trying to find
tickets bottom problem you know the
software developers have to be integral
of that and they obviously could go and
dig in the Python code but that's not
very efficient so we want the solute the
products to be valuable and and so CSPs
are good in that way they're terrible in
the sense that they're very inefficient
for an i/o perspective they have no way
to track they have no metadata of thing
we end up with these mile line mal long
filenames which is sort of silly so so
there's a lot of goodness in a solution
that can they can do better that we've
started doing a lot of stuff with hdf5
which is a lot faster it actually
supports metadata we've on some smaller
projects they've started taking
advantage of that haven't done that on
our larger projects but that's something
I would say this is again kind of our
weakest point and i'll hit at the end
kind of what we're looking at for for
next steps so then we got to come to
this this this last piece of of the
analysis and in my
I mean this is the one I worry the least
about because if we get the other stuff
right how we store the data and how we
kind of manage that process then this
can be somebody can kind of come to the
data with whatever solution they want
from a visualization standpoint but
we've done a lot of different things so
I'll show up kind of our static plots
and kind of talk about that in a second
but you know old school we were doing
this good new plot stuff you know now
everybody generally sticks with
matplotlib but it's always static
because we can't you know the only way
math letlive can be interactive if you
launch it out of Python and imagine if
you know we call a set time during the
mission where like something supposed to
happen like oh you know he's supposed to
fly into this threat and do this
maneuver that we call a run and so maybe
during tests you'd have let's say 12
runs and so I want to win a certain day
for certain aircraft in a certain run I
want to see some information well that
that would potentially create a set of
static grass they can't create
interactive graphs because I don't I
don't presuppose now obviously we could
and should and have begun to build in
smarter things like dashboards and
things like that but but historically
that hasn't been how it's been it's just
been creating lots and lots of these
graphs we we both have had great success
and and had problems with with the kind
of web-based solutions there's a lot of
goodness and you know and I kind of got
in renewed interest to go reattach a
bouquet which we've played with quite a
bit and for some of our smaller efforts
have used but the problem we've always
had is just the number of points and and
while you can go through the process of
kind of decimating the data that has its
problems and needless to say you can
lose critical points so we don't want to
do that if we don't have to you know
Sarah was talking yesterday about the
data shading piece to okay which we have
not played with extensively but you know
just in general you know JavaScript
doesn't like when you throw it a you
know a million points so it's figuring
out smart ways to handle that oh hi
cutie graph is is a 3d rendering engine
that has kind of two things that that we
found very appealing one is that it
natively uses the GPU and it has
phenomenal performance with lots and
lots of points very good performance and
also it's because it's got this kind of
QT base it's all built in
with the nice widget structure to go
build you know dashboards and things I
still think that we'd be much better off
sticking inside of a Jupiter you know
web-based stack and and if we can find a
way to do that and and still deal with
the mass amount of points that we have I
think that's where we'll end up so you
know to us as I mentioned before um the
the whole point to all this is kind of
that accessibility and and so we want
the we want people to be able to kind of
you know go ask questions to the data
and and because we didn't you know end
up creating a product that would have
nests ascend up in a situation where you
like okay here I am it isn't to say
where I would have wanted to be or
expect to be but here I am and and so
you know where we are is where we have
oh we found it easiest to go create a
whole bunch of information that then
somebody can go access as they need it
rather than having a method for somebody
to query the information in return quick
results you know as I said our day jobs
putting software on airplanes the data
thing is kind of something we fell into
and so it's always you know a trade-off
between you know what what what you
think you have time for in it and when
you end up down the road you're like wow
it's five years ago we would have done
this we would have been much happier but
at the time you're like you know we
don't have time for that so let's just
write more Python and kind of keep
building what we have which has been
somewhat of our our struggle we have the
benefit of a new project that we're
kicking off that that's going to have I
think a much larger amount of data and
it's all new data so we have the benefit
of kind of starting from scratch which
is a part of what kind of generated a
lot of our thinking on this topic of
kind of how we got here and what and
where we want to go so I want to other
things I want to mention on here
actually three other things so one is um
jinjja so I don't know if anyone's
familiar with that it's a templating
engine and uh you know it's it d3 for
anybody's done d3 is immensely
complicated it's like you know it's
great it's phenomenal it looks awesome
but it's not trivial and it's not to be
taken lightly but you can crib and off
from awesome d3 and use jinja in like in
30 seconds you can take your pants data
and put in some amazing d3 plot so for
crude you know trying to make sense out
of things
that has turned out to be a great tool
cesium is a web-based a graphics tool
that is very geo base and they do a lot
of work in kind of the the outer space
world which is in our world but but they
have a lot of built-in things for
visualizing a 3d that's been phenomenal
and again for smaller datasets it's been
very good and then the last thing is
that human image recognition I think
this was mentioned by somebody earlier
maybe was the saris talk this morning
you know to us it's a lot about putting
the right information in the hands of
the analyst or the engineer such that
they can figure out what's going on we
don't expect the software to figure out
what's going on I mean that goes back to
the beginning about this magical gonk
you later that gives you the right
answer we know that that isn't going to
happen so it's figuring out the right
information such that you know people
can look and they can see those those
nuanced differences or figure out you
know oh this is why things are happening
and a lot of times it's about giving
them many piece of information at once
ideally things are integrated together
where you're moving data and you're
getting a reactive displayed as etc so
um the static visualization piece so
this has kind of been the this is the
old school way we were doing things
producing bazillions of these these
files and you know the the one over on
the right is the basically it's showing
you like you know this would be for like
we're we're taking a reported a report
of where a sensor thinks something is
versus where it really is and we're
saying how much latitude alero and
longitudinal error and altitude air and
any go that's a phenomenal plot to have
if you know oh and run 12 of this day I
need to go look at that let plots there
and I go look at it but if I don't
necessarily know what's wrong and I have
a hundred thousand of these plots then
what i do right that doesn't mean zero
good um and so that's kind of what we've
been struggle with a little bit again
you know what I love is to have that but
that's interactive and then I kid you
know and that kind of gets that hold
dashboard thing which we've been trying
to figure out the right solution for us
here's another plot this is so one of
the things that we began to do is we
gathered all this data you we have you
know three hundred flights is to
aggregate a lot of information and we
actually were able to find things that
the program office for the aircraft
event thus the the prime the vendors
weren't aware of
here's an example here's a sensor that
ideally with lots and lots of data
points and I don't know how many data
points is but it's you know going to be
you know at least in the 50,000 I would
guess this is you would expect if you
had no bias in your system that that
graph on the right would be dead in the
crosshairs so what you see is that
there's bias imagine assets are looking
out into space from the from an aircraft
what you're seeing is bias basically
looking up in a little bit to the left
and so you can see you know elevation
angle is the angle you know kind of
coming off of the nose asmath angle is
is is going this way and and so you can
see you know that the azimuth angle is
kind of centered the error is and the
elevation angle is is a little over and
so and then again then in 3d now so this
is an example of you know the goodness
that we had when we went and basically
were able to aggregate tons and tons of
information which which our current
process is to go call through lots of
intermediate data to then create other
data and it becomes part of kind of this
pipeline so so this is actually the
project that created that again this is
kind of an example of a of a project but
have to be one of our larger projects
we're we end up creating this pipeline
basically through make files which I
don't know people are familiar with make
files but they they are a way that
usually people in the software building
world will kind of handle dependencies
and things like that and so that's kind
of how we used it here the problem is
and and was that it was a the pipeline
is is non-trivial for somebody to kind
of walk up and interact with except for
the handful people that kind of do the
care and feeding of it which is why you
know we really want to move that these
kinds of things to a much more robust
solution something like air flow or or
Luigi or something like that I'm sorry
little bit about that at the end as I
said that the philosophy had been rather
than trying to solve some of the hard
problems about you know resiliency I
mean a pedigree of the data in other
words okay I found a bug in this script
well what does that mean as far as all
of my myriad amount of intricate of
intermediate data you know I could do I
go figure out what the ramifications of
that were or do I just delete everything
and rerun it
is typically easier even though it takes
two to three days so that's kind of been
the philosophy which is is uh again you
can see how you could do that from a it
makes sense at the moment to just you
know rerun it but in a grand scheme it's
unacceptably long-winded so that's
something else we're trying to figure
out is smart ways to kind of manage some
of that there's pedigree issues and then
the goal is having an engineer that
isn't necessarily I mean you know
somebody is Python but is it intimately
familiar with all the pieces of this
process if you're able to walk up and
ask questions to the data so you know
recent project we were doing there's a
there's a rule out there that the FAA
has for flying in the u.s. called rvsm
now can you remember what the R stands
for but vertical separation a minimum
and it's basically it has to do with how
how we stack our airplane so we used to
stack them you know this far apart now
is saying this bar part in order to do
that everybody had to have goodness on
their 3d solution in how they calculate
their own position and how they monitor
the goodness that position well the FAA
mandated that a few years ago a lot of
military aircraft don't comply which
means they can't fly in the good air
space they have to fly in the crappy
airspace which is you're too low or too
high a lot less efficient lot less good
for fuel etc but so we were trying to do
compliance basically help them with
compliance we say we have this huge data
set we want to ask a simple question
tell me how you know give me every time
when I had an aircraft that flew
straight level for two minutes
hilariously we found very few
occurrences of this but the the data you
know that we were able to ask that
question and we're able to leverage this
intermediate result but it was not as
easy as you would like to be and the
ability for somebody to walk up and ask
questions is definitely a work in
progress so to kind of highlight some of
these hurdles so that last one you know
make it easy to jump on the train that
is not my train nor is that my metadata
Metallica sticker the resiliency of the
pipeline so managing you know keeping
that you know that blast radius low hit
you know making sure that as things
break that it doesn't make every you
know basically cause all sorts of issues
across the board which is you know been
a bit of a problem and I think why we
we're looking
migrate to a more of a managed pipeline
solution and then the pedigree issue so
so you know this is again smart ways to
manage you know how you know your data
is is is good when things change
upstream and again that's we don't have
a good solution right for that right now
and so metadata is a is a is a week
problem or is a problem in the in the
flight test community history you know
for the most part metadata doesn't come
with the data and a lot of times the
data the metadata you might want to know
is not is not even machine-readable it's
a lot of times information you have to
like collect from people like you know
what was on the airplane when it flew
you know what you know what specific
time you know type model series airplane
we're talking about you know all those
sorts of basic things isn't really
collected and so you know we've come up
with a database of that metadata that we
associate with all of our originating
data which is good so that part that
piece we saw what we haven't solved is
trying to iterate and kind of pull if
rate that information downstream so
excite as you try to find your email
results you can now ask those questions
our time on earlier I can you know know
what type monasteries airplane I am
right now we do that because we use the
file names which is under churches way
to do so kind of in in summary of you
know what we are looking at as far as
areas that you know kind of
investigating is you know some sort of
good workflow management and you know
I've got to ask up their kind of
separate I mean I think task is a
potential solution that would that would
be that would also be kind of this
workflow management piece but you know I
don't know if people are familiar with
air flow but air flow and there's other
tools like it i mean i mentioned three
of them pinball Luigi and air flow and
there's there's a myriad of other ones
but you know air flow I have some area
within you know for us you know give you
not only the ability it's basically you
define your dag and then it goes in it
decides how to run stuff you know right
now we manually figure all that out to
that make process and have to manage the
appendices manually it does all that but
it gives you a great visualization about
you know what r and win and then
statistics on you know what took the
longest and then historic
data on if things are you taking longer
than they should or whatever then they
used to and you can figure out you know
as you make code changes what the impact
is so something like that I think makes
makes a lot of sense for us um so I
mentioned some of the computation pieces
and that's something that we're
continuing to look at you know I we've
got I've got a co-worker of mine that
that continues to to say that if we did
it everything in sight on the life will
be much better I think he forgets that
we'd have to write C which we're trying
not to do um so so I got these a few of
these big data pieces down here and I
haven't really talked about that at all
but I'd say that as I mentioned we've
kind of got this other program kicking
off and we've been trying to decide what
that buys us in weather that makes sense
I mean clearly we are not a a big data
product in this typical sense and these
things these tools come with a lot of
baggage you know from a maintenance
standpoint and you know for us for every
time that we're managing a spark
installation is the same guy that would
otherwise be trying to make sense out of
data we don't have you know people that
are you know on the operations side of
house the other thing that makes our
life kind of complicated is all of our
analysis is air-gapped and so um that's
just painful in a myriad of ways right
uh so first of all you might say hey you
want to do spark go play data bricks you
load your data native Oracle play for
the while we can't do that we can't do
anything I mean you know we do we did
create a pretty good dataset
unclassified dataset using this thing
called a dsb which is a soon to be
mandated little transceiver that's going
to go on every airplane bigger than you
know relatively small and it's going to
basically disseminate and everybody
basically beacons out their position
constantly there's some great websites
uh that that show the pics to the earth
and UCLA airplanes flying pretty cool
spritzee there's there's feeds that you
can download the data and and so we've
done that and that's that's a very nice
data set it's at least somewhat we can
have a lot of data that way so we've
been playing we've actually got a
cluster setup and we've done some some
basic stuff we got desk up and running
but you know so you know so we've been
trying to to determine what the what the
right answer there is and whether it's
worth it I mentioned a so you
we try to pay attention to what West
McKinney's working on and he's involved
in ibis what kind of got his focus on
Ibis he's a cloud air guys so ibises got
this tide and Paula so if we were to do
the kind of more sequel side of the Big
Data solution you know that that seemed
like a starting point uh you know III
don't know yet if that you know first of
all we're not database people for the
most part and we don't want to write
sequel if we can help it so you know
we're looking for what the right the
right way to solve that is um i
mentioned i mentioned asked asked is a
you know kind of a scientific python
solution I think we have a comfort with
staying in that world uh but you know
again trying to see if it's the right
answer forest blaze is a little
different places basically a way to
what's the room for you know when you
make some anyway i'll come back to it uh
and then and then the clustering thing
so you know typically think of this is
is predictive you know machine learning
you think of something that we want to
create some predictive capability for us
the clustering we've we've been
experimenting with trying to learn from
the data through fostering you trying to
figure out what phenomenons are
associated together so you know i
noticed that when the aircraft gets
close to a ground threat it typically
gets terrible at figuring out where it
is well that's kind of obvious when the
RF is just terrible it you know when you
get close your intended pattern so maybe
sense but you could imagine that those
sorts of things the ones we don't know
about could be abstract away and that's
the word i couldn't REM earlier blaze
helps abstract your data um the soaked
so that's something we're looking at as
well so I appreciate I think we got a
couple minutes left I appreciate
everyone's time and hearing about kind
of our journey and and our continued
journey and and again if people you know
have thoughts on it we can we'd
certainly love to hear and you can grab
me or Jimmy at the at the bar later we
do have a couple minutes for questions
got first question not Jimmy
I am one with the postal service and
we're looking at a lot of telemetry data
from vehicle tracking right now and it's
fairly impoverished I'd guess compared
to your data it's simple lat launch
bearing speed and XYZ accelerometer
stuff and one of the challenges we've
been facing is to try to isolate events
like backing up or making a u-turn to
see if we can correlate those things
with accident rates could you speak to
how you used what methods you use for
isolating you know turning the stream of
telemetry into identifying the
meaningful event out of it so I would
say that that is something that we we've
tried a lot of things and we've had
varying levels of success I mean what we
found to be the most successful is
putting the data in the hands of
analysts to go figure it out which is a
which it can't be the right answer in
the big picture because you know part of
what we struggle with is it's a lot of
data and I can't I can't have somebody
look at all of it but what week so what
we have we have a run you know kind of
trend trend finding software mostly
stuff that we baked ourselves where we I
mentioned as part of this pipeline that
it does a bunch of tasks and one of
those tasks is a completely separate
process this job is simply to go and
find all sorts of error occurrences and
it's not just simply when the system
says it's error there's lots of things
that we've come to define as error
occurrences and we're able to graph
those over time and can see where they
align with things I mean you know as we
try to make sense out of sensor data you
typically you know if a pilot is looking
at his display and it doesn't do what he
wants it to do he typically blames the
correlator because it didn't make the
right decision and our job is always to
try to explain that that it typically
it's never our fault it's always the
sensors fault and and so it's it's a lot
of that kind of process of you know
identifying where sensors are falling
down so i don't i don't know i mean i
can say we definitely had that problem
and work through it but we don't have a
good solution i think part of what we'd
like to do with some of this clustering
work is to at least find relationships
and where things happen you know you
talk about you know backing up in action
rates things like that you know
the ability for me to basically run the
data sets that I can begin to see you
know the relationships between things
you know it's kind of I was very
inserting the last talked about the
graph theory and you know how they were
able to find a bunch of bunch of types
of relationships and that's a lot of
times what we're what we're trying to do
when we have so much data with so much
going on so hey just I guess a comment
and a question just with my database had
on you know I encourage your team to
investigate maybe multiple solutions
might really work well for you you know
maybe you need like a time series data
store a high-performance relational data
store and then documents store for
tracking metadata or something so don't
be afraid to you know to branch out and
what might make that easier and I guess
is my question is you know how are you
managing this is a kind of growing stack
of software is this something that
everybody's got personally I guess you
mentioned the system's air-gapped so I'm
kind of curious how the system itself is
managed haha I would almost say that man
is a strong word um so we we are
currently trying to get a condom server
basically in on our side of the air gap
but right now we typically I mean
everyone all of the Peter people are
doing by thon start with anaconda it's
only when we really branch outside of
what comes with the core anaconda we
have problems most of what we do we have
a couple of libraries but we end up with
basically have a repository of tar balls
and people go get stuff it's it's it's
art our team is it very big we do not
currently share environments and things
like that which is something that i like
but to be able to do you know there's a
you know but a lot of ways everybody is
on their own and we try to depend on EML
files and things like that for sharing
data and making sure the requirements
are well-defined but you know what ends
up happening is we've grown just to have
a lot of script software that you know
again it's like if you've known where
you were going you would have probably
taken a different road but but you end
up where you are and then you kinda have
to move forward I'm going to cut off the
questions now and let's give another
round of applause for Luke
thank you very much appreciate